I started being interesting laughs
original in connection to the Nephilim
birds in pies the hd2 to the
methodological Perea placated he stood
for pure and applied math here it's
mostly a Research Institute it's very
receptive for young people so we started
here already straight from the limpets
with Steve in high school at impact
denim consistence is a big part of him
and one researcher here started talking
to me
certain liking the problems and they
started with an inconsistency - one
example of dynamical system includes
this kind of of billiards that are very
simplified mathematical models to have
the ball that moves and reflects
elastically if the boundaries they can
consider something like a regular
pentagon instead of rectangular billiard
and you ask what are the properties of
disdain on causation so what happens to
the long-term behavior of the particle
so you could ask what's the difference
between the different polygons from the
point of view of dynamical systems you
were looking at the whole global
parameter space and one day I realized
that some of the things that I had
computed at the technical level for this
kind of more usual analysis that was
available protect and to call one
frequency Schrodinger operators was
possibly unlocking the possibilities to
having a view of the whole parameter
space I knew that there were things that
needed to be done on the technical side
but now it was within the realm of the
possible right now I spent part of my
time in Paris part of my time here in
the rear I like to work in a nice
setting walking along the beach you just
hear the waves and you can forget about
all the noise and so on they were
surprised when I heard that I got the
prize the president of the IMU sent me
an email asking for a phone number which
needs to contact me this moment I
understood that it was likely about
price I felt very happy most of all more
relaxed at that moment of course it's
good for both Brazil and France Brazil
never had wood meadow or Nobel Prize I
think to be very motivational for many
people here